bien bonjour à toutes et à tous un
je m'appelle sylvain laserman je viens
d'alsace comme vous en rendrez compte
lors de l'animation de cette table ronde
je suis très heureux je suis très
heureux
d'animer cette table ronde sur un sujet
majeur de l'égalité des chances alors
rappelons nous que les distinctions
sociales ne peuvent être fondées que sur
l'utilité commune la question la
question de beaucoup de politiques
publiques c'est comment donner la même
chance à tout le monde comment être
beaucoup parlent d' inégalité juste
c'est à dire fondée sur l'engagement de
chacun sur les talents de chacun et pas
sur
la catégorie socioprofessionnelle de vos
parents sur votre origine ou sur notre
condition sociale
nous avons des invités de marque pour
aborder ce sujet et nous allons
commencer si vous le voulez bien par le
commencement est le commencement c'est
l'éducation alors nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir nathalie et limaces alors
nathalie vous vous la connaissez elle a
commencé sa carrière dans les rh je
crois
elle est elle a été conseiller régional
d'ile-de-france député du val d'oise en
2017 elle est aujourd'hui secrétaire
d'état sur l'éducation prioritaire
nathalie j'aimerais commencer par par
une question assez simple dans ma
circonscription il ya des quartiers
prioritaires politique de la ville
notamment au neuhof et j'étais avec une
enseignante de classe de cp qui me
disait écoutez monsieur débuter c'est
facile on parlait des 12 enfants par
classe si on essayait de faire un peu un
retour d'expérience elle me disais c'est
facile on a quatre classes de cp jusqu'à
présent on avait quatre à cinq enfants
par classe qui n'étaient pas rentrés
dans la lecture à la fin du cp
autant vous dire que le reste de leur
cadre de leur cursus était un peu
compromis aujourd'hui on attaque un sur
les quatre classes ça veut dire dans ma
petite école de neovia quatre classes de
cp 20 enfants à qui on redonne une
chance supplémentaire alors chers
nathalie le dédoublement des classes
est-ce que c'est pas finalement une
réforme absolument fondamental de ce
quinquennat qu'il faut sur lequel il
faut revenir
merci sylvain bonjour à tous mesdames et
monsieur alors je savais je suis très à
cheval sur l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes etc et je note quand même que
sur une table ronde pour l'égalité des
chances il n'y a qu'un homme je dis ça
comme ça
donc merci grand merci grand merci à toi
patrick merci sylvain le dédoublement
des classes pour moi c'est probablement
la plus belle mesure d'égalité des
chances elle a été portée par ce
quinquennat elle a été évidemment mise
en place par notre ministre de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse et
des sports qui discutera avec nous tout
à l'heure jean michel blanquer on a
dédoublé 100% des classes de cp et de
ce1 en éducation prioritaire et on voit
déjà très concrètement les résultats
parce que ces premières cohortes dia de
2017 sont aujourd'hui en fin d'école
élémentaire et on voit que l'objectif a
été atteint l'objectif c'était de
permettre à ces enfants de petite classe
dans les quartiers mais pas
exclusivement parce que l'éducation
prioritaire c'est pas que le quartier
politique de la ville c'est pas que le
quartier urbain c'est aussi la petite
ville c'est la zone rurale c'est en
savoie par exemple chez patrick la
montagne bref l'éducation prioritaire
c'est partout et c'est permettre à ces
enfants qui ne sont pas tous alignés sur
la ligne de départ est bien d'avoir
toutes les chances de s'engager dans
leur poursuite d'études en sachant
correctement maîtrisé les fondamentaux
qui sont lire écrire compter
et maintenant respecter autrui donc on a
dédoublé toutes ses classes on est en
train de dédoubler les classes de grande
section et pour faire beaucoup de
terrain pour aller partout dans les
écoles toutes les semaines je peux vous
dire que c'est un plébiscite c'est un
plébiscite des parents qui mettent leurs
enfants à l'école en confiance c'est un
plébiscite des professeurs qui nous
disent que dans les classes désormais il
n'y a plus d'enfants invisible quand on
a 12 enfants quatorze enfants devant soi
à qui on apprend à lire et à écrire on
est capable de travailler
individuellement avec chacun d'entre eux
et puis les enfants sont sereins ils
sont contents d'être à l'école et donc
c'est une
très très belle mesure je le disais il y
en a d'autres bien évidemment j'ai la
charge de
de l'éducation prioritaire
c'est un secrétariat d'état qui a été
créé l'année dernière première sous la
vème république ça n'existait pas
auparavant c'est dire la volonté très
forte et de jean michel blanc coeur et
évidemment du président de la république
de pouvoir actionner tous les leviers en
faveur de l'égalité des chances
l'égalité des chances pour nos enfants
c'est bien sûr lutter contre les
inégalités éducatives
c'est lutter contre les inégalités
sociales et c'est aussi lutter contre
les inégalités tauriac territoriale
alors je vais pas vous faire un
catalogue d'abord on n'a pas le temps je
crois que je n'ai que cinq 5 minutes de
temps de parole et si le vent est très
très réglementaire mais je donc je vais
plutôt vous parler d'expériences de
terrain vient de vous parler des
dédoublements de classes et encore une
fois c'est un plébiscite dans toutes les
écoles vous le savez j'étais
précédemment députés j'ai là d'ailleurs
mon ancien président de groupe j'étais
membre de la commission des affaires
sociales et c'est une fibre chez moi qui
est très développé et donc quand je suis
arrivée au secrétariat d'état j'ai voulu
impulser très fort une politique sociale
au sein du ministère de l'éducation
nationale et je me suis battu je
vraiment je me suis battu pour remettre
en place les petits déjeuners gratuits à
l'école c'est aussi une mesure d'égalité
des chances et quand je dis que je me
suis battu c'est que quand je suis allé
porter mon dossier au prix au niveau on
m'a dit bon attention l'assistanat voilà
sauf que j'ai encore une fois je vais
vous parler d'expériences de terrain
quand vous allez dans le nord je dirai
pas où dans une petite école qui cumule
toutes les difficultés la précarité les
difficultés sociales les difficultés
économiques les addictions parfois des
violences intrafamiliales et que la
directrice d'école vous dit vous savez
madame la ministre je devrais pas le
dire mais je le fais quand même ici dans
mon école il ya des enfants qui avant
d'arriver le matin se lève plus tôt et
font les poubelles pour aller manger et
bien là je peux vous dire que je suis
très contente d'avoir remis en place les
petits déjeuners gratuits à l'école et
c'est pas de l'assistanat
voilà c'est une belle mesure
elle mesure d'égalité des chances ça
vaut je parlais du nord mais quand à
mayotte un chef d'établissement me dis
au collège n'y a pas de cantine c'est
pas possible les enfants ne mangent pas
eh bien on est content distribué des
petits déjeuners gratuits à l'école
voilà typiquement ce que je voulais vous
dire il ya tant d'autres mesures il ya
tant d'autres mesures je pensais aussi
vous parler de nos internats
d'excellence par exemple qui permettent
à nos jeunes en collège ou en lycée
d'accéder à un cadre bienveillant un
enseignement très qualitatif
ça leur permet d'être parfois extrait
d'un milieu social qui est complexe ça
permet à nos jeunes qui sont en milieu
rural est bien de de rêver d'anticiper
de se projeter dans leur poursuite
d'études parce que parfois quand on est
collégien ou lycéen dans un village qui
a pas de carte de formations adaptées à
côté qu'il faut des heures pour aller à
l'école pour aller au collège etc eh
bien on a un petit peu tendance à se
refermer et ça on l'a fait on a
labellisé bon nombre d'internats
d'excellence et là encore
j'étais dans l'est récemment dans un
internat j'avais devant moi cinq jeunes
dont un qui me disait je suis très
heureux d'être là parce que j'ai fait
une sortie de route j'avais arrêté les
études j'avais plus envie d'aller à
l'école j'étais en train de basculer
dans la délinquance et puis on m'a
proposé de venir dans un internat
d'excellence aujourd'hui je suis très
content d'être là j'ai repris mes études
et j'ai même remonter mais moyenne voilà
donc autant de levier d'égalité des
chances
qu'il faut absolument instaurer et
réinstaurer à l'école on l'a fait avec
jean michel blanquer avec beaucoup de
conviction beaucoup d'ambitions parce
qu'on a énormément d'ambition pour nos
jeunes et effectivement c'est là c'est
le terreau je te disais ils ne sont pas
tous sur la même ligne au départ mais
notre ambition c'est de faire en sorte
qu'ils arrivent tous sur la ligne
d'arrivée quelle que soit la ligne
d'arrivée parce que poursuivre ses
études c'est pas forcément vers une
grande école ou aller à l'université
c'est peut-être aussi s'engager dans un
parcours de formation
et là encore on a permis à bon nombre de
jeunes d'entrer dans l'apprentissage
c'est peut-être vouloir devenir boucher
ou travailler je ne sais où dans un
métier manuel peu importe l'essentiel et
c'est vraiment ce que l'on a construit
notamment tu le disais c'est le point de
départ c'est le dédoublement des classes
et bien c'est d'asseoir ses enfants sur
des fondamentaux leur apprendre à lire à
écrire à compter correctement leur
donner les valeurs et puis en plus si on
peut leur permettre d'arriver à l'école
le ventre vide eh bien ils remplissent
beaucoup plus vite leur tête le ventre
plein on avait on avait compris merci
beaucoup alors on va prendre les
interventions de cinq minutes chacun et
puis après évidemment on aura une
possibilité de poser des questions et
les réponses et d'avoir des réponses
juste pour l'anecdote quand nathalie est
venu à strasbourg il ya une famille une
maman qui est venu me voir et qui m'a
dit j'ai un message que vous
transmettiez à la ministre elle avait
deux enfants son premier avait été avant
le dispositif de dédoublements dans une
classe avec avec
28 élèves et le second était en classe à
12 élèves il se trouve que le second
avait un léger handicap et elle m'a dit
il à l'enseignant l'a repéré la première
semaine ils ont mis un dispositif en
place si ça avait été mon aîné je suis
sûr qu'il serait passer à côté et donc
voilà à chaque témoignage comme ça on se
dit que la politique ça sert à quelque
chose et les actions que tu mènes sont
absolument fondamentales merci beaucoup
à tallinn alors
nous allons passer maintenant à ilana
sécurel vous êtes débuté européenne
délégué chargé de l'éducation du rex de
la m en 2017 en 2018 vous lancez le
collectif je m'engage pour l'école et ce
qui m'a beaucoup intéressé en tant que
alsacien donc frontaliers c'est que vous
avez écrit un rapport et j'ai relu trois
fois mais c'est bien mobilité et
partenariats européens un enjeu pour la
transformation du système éducatif
français et pour avoir vu l'impact des
échanges entre des classes allemande et
des classes françaises il en alsace chez
nous je ne peux qu'adhérer à cette
nécessité pour nous de nous bousculer un
peu dans nos habitudes et de s'ouvrir à
des expériences différentes je vous
laisse la parole yens
bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous et
puis merci de cet accueil je suis en
tant que
députée européenne l'arrêt mais membres
de renaissance ayant d'ailleurs le goût
de cette maison commune qui nous
attendent ou c'est notre quotidien et je
dois dire que c'est un vrai plaisir de
travailler notamment avec sylvie qui est
une amie à une complice de tous les
combats et je crois que ça doit nous
rendre optimiste voilà c'était un petit
préambule écoutez je crois que toutes et
tous autant que nous sommes ici nous
sommes désengagés sinon nous serions pas
là et avant d'être désengagé nous sommes
des indignés forcément et dans
l'indignation qui moi personnellement ma
mise en ma mise en mouvement m'a mise en
plus exactement il y à l'indignation
devant le recul de l'égalité des chances
dans notre pays qui se résume dans deux
données factuelles qui sont très
frappante la première c'est que 20% des
élèves de notre pays quitte le cm2 sans
savoir lire écrire compter ça c'était
avant évidemment tout ce que nous avons
mis en place mais c'est une donnée et la
deuxième c'est que nous portons une très
triste médaille selon pisa nous sommes
parmi les pays où les déterminismes
sociaux pèsent le plus lourd sur le
parcours scolaire des enfants nous
sommes tout simplement les champions
dans le pays de jules ferry c'est pour
moi quelque chose auquel je pense
quasiment tous les matins c'est le
moteur de mon engagement et je crois et
ça vient d'être rappelée je fais je veux
rendre hommage évidemment à l'action de
jean michel blanquer à celle de nathalie
que nous devons collectivement être très
fiers de ce que nous avons fait et
notamment le dédoublement des classes en
grande section puisque ça commence
maintenant en cp et ce1 je crois que les
résultats sont là et je crois que ça a
aussi été un révélateur un révélateur de
quoi et ça doit aussi nous rendre
optimiste c'est que notre pays est
encore un pays qui a la passion de
l'égalité
80% plus de 80 % de nos concitoyens sont
très favorables à cette mesure et ils
sont très loin d'être 80% à en
bénéficier donc on voit bien que c'est
encore la passion d'égalité qui est un
moteur et moi ce dont je voulais vous
parler ce matin c'est que cette passion
de l'égalité eh bien je sens qu'elle est
en train de s'installer au niveau
européen comme vous le savez le
l'éducation n'est pas une compétence
européenne c'est ce qu'on appelle une
compétence de soutien et elle avait
parfois tendance à ne pas être
considérés comme absolument
primordial dans le projet européen c'est
en train de changer c'est vrai que le
coc vide est passée par là et de plus en
plus ce que je ressens et c'est aussi
vrai pour la formation formation et
éducation vont de pair eh bien de plus
en plus elle est perçue au niveau
européen comme un enjeu stratégique
un enjeu stratégique et je vais vous
donner un exemple pour la première fois
de l'histoire de l'union il y a eu une
réunion des ministres européens de
l'éducation et des ministres européens
des finances autour de la question de
l'éducation comme investissement et avec
des économies ce très sérieux qui
travaillent sur la question de savoir et
bien justement que kitsch qui cherche à
mesurer de manière très scientifique
quand vous investissez dans l'éducation
eh bien vous produisez de la richesse la
compétence et de la richesse mais vous
faites faire aussi à vos pays des
économies absolument massive en terme de
chômage en termes de santé en termes de
sécurité donc ça c'est un changement de
paradigme qui est en train de
s'installer et qui fait que l'éducation
est en train de devenir un enjeu
stratégique et je crois que toutes et
tous nous devons pousser cette tendance
alors je vais en donner quelques
exemples il ya bien sûr
le doublement le quasi doublement
d'erasmus c'est à dire des moyens
supplémentaires il y à cette année qui
va être l'année 2022 l'année de la
jeunesse comme ça a été annoncé par
ursula von der leyen dans dans son
discours sur sur l'état de l'union c'est
évidemment décidé en bonne intelligence
avec le président macron et sa annonce
aussi un engagement très fort sur la
jeunesse en faveur de la jeunesse il ya
eu aussi quelque chose qui est passée un
peu inaperçue celle annonce du projet
alma qui en parallèle d'erasmus va être
un projet de mobilité pour les jeunes
qui sont d'inite c'est à dire qu'ils
sont ni en emploi ni information ni en
éducation et eux vont aussi avoir des
moyens de faire cette expérience
européenne donc tout ça ce sont des
signaux extrêmement favorable le
doublement d'erasmus c'est très bien
mais il ya une priorité que nous portons
au parlement européen c'est que cette
ses moyens démultipliez hills high
d'abord et avant tout vers la jeunesse
qui est éloigné de l'europe car très
souvent la jeunesse et douaniers de
l'europe elle est aussi éloignée de la
réussite et c'est pour ça que nous
sommes tellement attaché à ce que à
développer la mobilité des apprentis
alors ça a été évoqué tout à l'heure et
moi je voulais partager avec vous une
très bonne nouvelle
petit point technique vous savez
dans quand quand vous avez un vote au
parlement au pire vous avez des vous
avez des compromis entre groupes
politiques et bien nous avons décidé de
faire rentrer dans le texte qui va être
votée à la fin de l'année sur l'espace
européen de l'éducation l'objectif de
voter un statut européen de l'apprenti
en mobilité pour pouvoir enfin
trouver des solutions à tous les freins
assez mobilité des apprentis alors pour
terminer je vais dire un mot de ma
mission la mission qui m'a été confiée
par par jean michel blanquer et clément
bonne et là encore
l'objectif était de toucher toute notre
jeunesse et j'ai trouvé deux leviers le
premier levier c'est de passer par les
professeurs et notamment les futurs
professeurs et il a été décidé dès cette
rentrée que tous les futurs professeurs
et progressivement ça va concerner toute
une cohorte auront une expérience dans
pendant alors leurs formations feront un
stage dans un pays européen et ensuite
ils auront aussi un module europe qui va
les initier à toutes les bonnes
pratiques européennes à tout ce que peut
apporter cette pratique donc on va avoir
une nouvelle génération de professeurs
qui va arriver dans le système avec
cette culture aux européennes et la deux
le deuxième levier fondamental c'est
100% de jumelage c'est à dire le
jumelage pour tous les établissements
français aujourd'hui on est à 48 % on
veut arriver en 2022 à 100% donc je sais
qu'il ya beaucoup d'élus dans la salle
on a besoin de vous on a une vraie
stratégie qui est proposé dans ce
rapport qui sera rendu d'ailleurs public
cette semaine et sur le site de
l'éducation nationale et l'idée c'est
vraiment de travailler par bassin de vie
c'est à dire vraiment d'avoir en tête
justement la ruralité les zones
enclavées les zones prioritaires donc ça
c'est très important et je veux terminer
là dessus c'est que ce dont je suis
heureuse c'est que je sens que j'ai
contribué par cette mission mais je
crois que nous allons tous contribuer à
notre manière de faire de l'europe un
élément d'évaluation des écoles ah bon
établissement scolaire un établissement
qui est en pleine vitalité il est ouvert
sur l'europe et il ya un enjeu pour
l'égalité des chances et ça j'en
terminerai par là c'est quelque chose
que je vois je
députée européene de terrain je ne passe
beaucoup de temps dans les écoles dès
que vous mettez de l'europe eh bien vous
récupérez d'abord des équipes et
pédagogique qui travaille ensemble on
sait que c'est l'une des grandes
faiblesses en france elle travaille tout
d'un coup en projet forcément ensuite
vous avez des jeunes qui reprennent
confiance les l'horizon s'élargit
évidemment vous avez
toute une vous avez un apaisement du
climat scolaire ça nous a été dit par
tous les chefs d'établissement dans les
zones les plus difficiles donc l'europe
oui c'est une clé d'abord parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de fonds européens pourra
peut-être en reparler à travers les
questions mais c'est une clé aussi de
transformation
aussi pour l'égalité des chances nous
devons enfin nous saisir de ce trésor
pédagogique qui est cette diversité
pédagogique de l'europe dont nous
n'avons jamais pour l'instant était
capable vraiment de nous emparer et il y
a aujourd'hui notamment à travers les
académies européenne des professeurs des
moyens de le faire donc je suis ravi de
cette table ronde et je vous invite je
sais que nous avons un beau chemin à
faire ensemble l'éducation j'en suis
convaincu aura un rôle structurant dans
la campagne et je crois que nous sommes
les seuls face aux cassandres qui ne
savent que capitaliser sur les peurs des
français nous sommes les seuls à pouvoir
écrire un chemin d'espérance et je
serais ravi d'y travailler avec vous
merci vous couvre ces belles paroles
donc rendez vous est pris pour la
lecture de votre rapport publié donc
cette semaine vous parlez de l'exemple
d'autres pays européens vous avez abordé
la thématique l'apprentissage donc les
enfants grandissent après l'égalité des
chances à l'école il a lesquels
l'égalité des chances dans l'acquisition
des compétences dans leur parcours de
vie
j'aimerais vous dire
vous parlez en deux mots de
l'apprentissage on va on sait ça a été
un point abordé par par plusieurs
d'entre vous je vous rappelle quand même
les chiffres
en alsace on on avait toujours tendance
à dire que l'apprentissage en allemagne
était beaucoup plus performant qu'il ne
l'était en france au début de ce mandat
on a fait une réforme une réforme qui
globalement sans rentrer dans les
détails donne plus de poids aux
entreprises pour choisir dans quel
secteur économique dans quelle activité
il faut former combien de jeunes mais le
résultat est là
280 mille jeunes en apprentissage la
dernière année du quinquennat hollande
520 mille jeunes aujourd'hui donc ça
c'est concret c'est clair c'est l'impact
direct d'une réforme qui m'est fait qui
met fin à vingt ans pendant lesquels on
a entendu sans relâche expliqué qu'il
fallait faire enfin réussir
l'apprentissage en france ça c'est un
point majeur alors on va passer la
parole sur ça et sur d'autres
thématiques de d'acquisition des
compétences à caroline célèbre conte est
très heureuse de vous accueillir vous
avez été à l'origine formé en droit
social vous avez dirigé des activités
sur les politiques de l'emploi de
formation d'orientation vous avez
accompagné beaucoup de deux missions en
la matière et vous êtes depuis fin
d'année dernière au commissaire aux
compétences alors j'ai trouvé une
citation je trouve très belle que je
partage avec vous qui est de dire que
votre objectif est la définition
d'égalité des chances pour vous en tout
cas une partie c'est de redonner par la
formation professionnelle à chacun le
pouvoir d'agir sur sa trajectoire
professionnelle et personnelle et
finalement c'est une très belle façon de
de dire les choses et n'oublions pas que
le président de la république avait
avait donné comme feuille de route de
d'aller chercher ceux qui pensent que la
formation n'est pas pour eux alors
karine merci beaucoup d'être là je vous
laisse la parole merci beaucoup merci de
l'invitation et et aussi de me permettre
de d'échanger avec vous sur ce thème qui
me tient effectivement beaucoup à coeur
moi j'ai l'immense responsabilité de
mettre en place le plan d'investissement
dans les compétences qui est un plan qui
a été voulu par le président de la
république au début du quinquennat
qui est un plan de 15 milliards d'euros
sur les cinq ans pour permettre à ceux
qui sont peut être les oubliés du
système d'accéder à la formation est
donc à l'égalité des chances et la
capacité de peser sur leur parcours et
de retrouver leur pouvoir d'agir
c'est donc un plan qui vise à former sur
l'ensemble du quinquennat quinquennat
par dont deux millions de jeunes sans
qualification et de demandeurs d'emplois
peu ou pas qualifiés pour leur permettre
de se projeter vers l'avenir et trouver
un emploi donc ces deux millions fin
crosswood on va quasiment sur le
quinquennat doubler le nombre de
personnes à la recherche d'emploi qui se
forment
c'est un ambitieux objectif très
ambitieux et effectivement ce
quinquennat aura fait en matière
d'égalité des chances des actions très
forte qui sont pas que des infos qui
sont pas que symbolique et dont on
pensait parce que moi ça fait
effectivement longtemps que je
m'intéresse à ces sujets que c'était
impossible imaginez cinq ans en arrière
l'idée de dire on va dédoubler les
classes dans les quartiers prioritaires
de la ville en
cp c'est enfin tout le monde aurait
pensé que c'était impossible et on l'a
fait on a effectivement plus que
multiplié par deux le nombre de jeunes
en apprentissage et on va d'où enfin
quasiment doublé le nombre de demandeur
d'emploi qui se forment
grosso modo avant le quinquennat il y
avait à peu près de l'ordre de 10% de
chômeurs qui se formait un sur dix
on a fait un bilan mi parcours qui est
un peu plus d'un an maintenant on était
à 16% et on va tourner et on est à va
être à 18% en fin d'année on va
continuer à progresser donc on est
quasiment en train de doubler le nombre
de demandeurs d'emploi qui se forme
derrière ces chiffres c'est pas
simplement des statistiques ce sont des
hommes et des femmes des jeunes et des
moins jeunes qui sont souvent sorti trop
de pain taux du système scolaire donc
peu qualifiés ou qui qui retrouve la
dignité ce sont des femmes qui explique
qu'ils étaient en situation
d'illettrisme qui explique que grâce à
la formation qu'elles ont eues on
retrouvait là la dignité fin c'est plus
que la dignité c'est la capacité
d'accompagner leurs propres enfants dans
leurs devoirs scolaires
c'est voilà et donc ce sont on pourrait
citer beaucoup d'exemples qui sont
extrêmement touchant mais surtout qu'ils
sont porteurs d'avenir parce qu'on est
en train de de donner à ces
personnes c'est encore une fois ça sera
plus de deux millions de personnes
supplémentaires à qui on va donner
pendant le quinquennat la capacité
d'agir moi j'ai tendance à dire pourquoi
on a choisi de 20 c'était quoi la
volonté du plan d'investissement dans
les compétences c'était d'arroser là où
c'est pas déjà mouillé et ça c'est
vraiment la question de l'égalité des
chances en matière de formation
professionnelle
grosso modo notre système fort mais ceux
qui sont déjà qualifiés pour lequel
l'idée de se projeter dans l'avenir et
de se remettre ils ont peut se remettre
en question quand on a déjà un bagage
culturel social éducatif vous et moi
enfin en tout cas l'idée qu'on va
refaire une formation ça nous remet pas
en question pour des gens qui ont quitté
l'école relativement tôt c'est une
remise en question et c'est quelque
chose de très important de pouvoir
redonner ce pouvoir est de dire on va
arroser là où c'est pas déjà mouillé on
va porter l'effort une attention
particulière sur ces publics vulnérables
donc voilà je voulais d'abord vous dire
ça parce que d'abord en
c'est une grande fierté de porter ce
programme et surtout ça ça change
finalement le pouvoir des gens leur
capacité à se projeter dans dans les
actions qu'on conduit alors je ne vais
pas évidemment toutes les citer il y en
a de très nombreuses mais on a notamment
une attention particulière pour les
publics vulnérables pour les jeunes
sortis sans qualification du système
scolaire
on espère d'ailleurs grâce aux angles
aux actions de nathalie notamment et on
on voit bien que ça va produire des
conséquences qu'on en aura moins à
l'avenir
on a encore aujourd'hui des jeunes
sortis sans qualification de seine
scolaires ont fait un énorme travail de
ce qu'on appelait le repérage des
invisibles
pour aller
chercher ceux qui sont sortis des radars
ceux qui ne croient plus dans les
institutions ce qui ne pousse plus la
porte de nos services publics qui ont
disparu pour aller repérer là où ils
sont avec des associations sportives
parfois en faisant
en allant dans un resto du coeur ou dans
des
lieux de banques alimentaires pour
reprofiler retisser des liens évidemment
dans les barres d'immeubles il ya un
énorme travail de repérage des
invisibles on a repéré depuis le début
grâce à un appel à projet qu'on a lancé
plus de soixante mille jeunes ce sont 90
% des jeunes
la moitié sont 56% ne sont pas qualifiés
n'ont jamais eu de diplôme
plus des hommes c'est 60% des hommes des
jeunes hommes que des filles mais il ya
quand même évidemment beaucoup de filles
et un quart se déclare décrocheurs et et
derrière évidemment ce repérage c'est un
travail de remobilisation pour les
remettre en lien pour leur proposer
ensuite d'aller vers l'apprentissage
vers de la formation vers du service
civique en fait vers quelque chose qui
les remet en mouvement mais ce sont
aussi des actions à l'égard des adultes
on a notamment
programme de prêts très forte
progression du nombre de bénéficiaires
du rsa qui se forment vous savez qu'on a
parlé mais aussi beaucoup de la question
pour doc est très importante c'est que
il faut mettre en mouvement les gens il
faut leur proposer des solutions et on a
on est passé de 16% de bénéficier du rsa
qui se formaient à 24% donc une
progression qui est très importante et
c'est le doux lire c'est à dire c'est le
double de ce qu'il représente dans la
dent dans la demande d'emploi donc on a
vraiment une mise en dynamique qui est
très importante et puis je voudrais
finir d'un mot pour dire que la
l'égalité des chances c'est évidemment
s'intéresser à ces publics vulnérables
temps de la main mais là aussi ce n'est
pas de l'assistanat pour remettre en
mouvement parce que c'est aussi c'est la
question de notre cohésion sociale qui
est en jeu et c'est vraiment essentiel
mais l'égalité des chances c'est pas que
les plus vulnérables c'est aussi faire
en sorte que effectivement on redonne du
pouvoir d'agir qu'on permette à
l'ensemble on sait qu'on va changer de
carrière au cours de sa vie
professionnelle grosso modo 4 à 5 fois
et donc la capacité à se former c'est
quelque chose aussi qui doit devenir
sinon banal parce que se former c'est
jamais un acte banal en tout cas à
banaliser et moi je rêve d'un monde et
c'est à ça qu'on dit que nous on agit ou
finalement l'idée de retourner en
formation quand on est adulte n'est pas
une remise en question mais au contraire
un atout et c'est ça qui donne du
pouvoir d'agir donc grands n'ont pas la
formation banal la formation s'est
jamais banal mais par contre la
banaliser c'est faire en sorte que par
la forme à la validation des acquis de
l'expérience
on peut reconnaître ce qu'on a acquis
dans la vie associative dans la vie
politique ou dans la vie professionnelle
et le faire reconnaître c'est faire
reconnaître ses compétences par les
pairs et voilà faire en sorte que la
formation devienne un acte indispensable
et rendre les gens fiers finalement de
ce qu'ils apprennent au quotidien voilà
aussi ce que nous sommes en train de
construire merci merci beaucoup car il
alors après l'école après l'école après
l'apprentissage et l'acquisition des
compétences il ya l'accès à l'emploi je
suis très sensible à cette thématique là
pour l'anecdote j'ai lancé une
initiative dans ma circonscription on
accompagne 300 jeunes
anecdote en accompagne 300 jeunes avec
sans coach bénévoles
en fait c'est des jeunes qui n'ont pas
la chance d'avoir dans leur
environnement familial la maman qui est
cadre supérieur en entreprise le l'oncle
qui peut briefé donner les codes de
l'entreprise etc on s'aperçoit en fait
que ce coaching marche bien pourquoi
parce qu'on essaie de compenser cette
perte de chance et que sais-je allons
évidemment beaucoup de valeur beaucoup
de beaucoup d'engagement beaucoup de
réussite quand même jeu en un seul appel
on a eu 55 coach on a lancé ça en début
d'année qui ont répondu présent 55 ont
un seul appel on suit 80 jeunes
le seul critère c'est trouver un cdi ou
un cdd plus petits mois on a déjà 21 qui
ont trouvé on continue mais je crois que
ça illustre bien ça illustre bien cette
notion de même si vous avez le bon
diplôme
si vous avez réussi à l'école vous avez
le bon diplôme vous êtes quand même pas
sur la même ligne de départ si vous ne
connaissez pas les codes de l'entreprise
si vous n'avez pas les réseaux si vous
n'avez pas des gens qui peut vous entre
vous vous entraînez aux entretiens de
recrutement et tous ces jeunes étaient
évidemment passer par pôle emploi et les
missions locales mais qui n'ont pas le
temps matériel de faire cet
accompagnement et cet esprit d'équipé
jusqu'à l'objectif de l'emploi alors
sylvie je suis vraiment très heureux que
tu sois là sylvie est professeur associé
à laquelle kate winslet school où a été
présidente également a été pardon
présidente de la section travail et
emploi au conseil économique social et
environnemental
elle est aujourd'hui évidemment députée
européenne extrêmement engagés dans la
notion d'emploi et d'accès à l'emploi
sylvie on est très heureux qu'ils soient
avec nous je te laisse la parole merci
beaucoup
goûter c'est je voudrais commencer par
dire que le sujet que le bouton
l'égalité des chances je pense que c'est
un des sujets les plus importants pour
toutes les échéances politiques à venir
vraiment c'est le sujet majeur je pense
que le modem le portent particulièrement
c'est dans l'adn de notre parti j'ai
toujours entendu notre président en
parler peut-être mieux que quiconque
parce que c'est vraiment dans l'adn de
du modèle alors je voudrais commencer
par quelques points alors d'abord ravi
de retrouver ilana karine patrick bien
sûr et nathalie puisque finalement on a
on est on travaille tous sur des chaînes
dans la chaîne de cette problématique à
un niveau ou à un autre je voudrais
quand même commencé par dire puisque
maintenant je suis députée européenne
j'avais été frappé lors d'un débat
d'entendre
une experte de l' ocde dire que c'est un
vrai sujet en france
on se compare souvent avec l'allemagne
en france 40% des personnes qui
travaillent se trouvent des classes
c'est à dire sur qualifié par rapport à
ce qu'elles font contre 20 % made man
c'est vraiment une caractéristique en
france qui est importante
ce sentiment bon d'être alan
surqualifiés pas vraiment à sa place
donc c'est un vrai sujet chez nous
qu'est ce qui se passe au fond dans
toute cette chaîne sur le marché du
travail à l'axé alors on a parlé de
l'apprentissage
j'ai eu l'honneur de présider la
concertation préalable à la réforme de
l'apprentissage des quatre mois de
débats être concertation pour arriver à
cette réforme dont personnellement je
suis très fier je pense est une très
belle réforme de notre quinquennat on
voit les chiffres mais au-delà de ça
c'était vraiment placé aussi le curseur
au bon endroit là aussi à l'époque on
faisait déjà des comparatifs avec
d'autres pays suisse allemagne il est
évident qu'il ya un lien très claire
entre le chômage des jeunes en tout cas
l'emploi des jeunes et la réussite de
l'alternance et de l'apprentissage
donc puisqu'on le voit au niveau des
chiffres au passage on s'est amélioré en
france sur le taux de chômage des jeunes
de moins de 25 ans on reste quand même
assez élevé avec en 2021 on est à 18 6%
de chômage des jeunes
allemagne 6 5 on a encore un gap mais
espagne 37,7 donc on est quand même et
pour une moyenne en europe de 16% il
faut le dire avec le lac au vide et la
crise pandémique une augmentation quand
même deux on a plus 300 mille jeunes qui
sont en difficulté au chômage donc je
cite quand même c'est chez ces chiffres
importants alors moi ce que je voulais
dire finalement en résumé j'avais envie
de citer finalement des jeunes eux mêmes
parce que j'ai la chance
d'abord d'être vice président de la
mission locale de marseille c'est la
plus grande de france c'est 25000 jeunes
qui sont suivis par an
alors j'ai toujours tenu à être à la
fois un niveau c'est vrai on a la chance
d'être parlement européen de travailler
sur des textes fondateurs sur tous les
sujets sociaux emploi la garantie jeunes
peu savent que c'est un dispositif
européen qui a été créée en 2009
première grande crise financière mais
les écoles de la deuxième chance est un
dispositif un repère aussi voilà il ya
beaucoup de dispositifs qui sont nés de
l'europe j'ai la chance de pouvoir être
aussi sur le terrain et de voir comment
on peut transformer ce que nous
concevons parfois un certain niveau sur
le terrain alors je voudrais citer
finalement les jeunes parce que sur un
premier sujet qui me semble fondamental
donc en 2019 j'étais encore président de
la section travail et emploi c'est ce
conseil économique social
environnemental et nous avions fait des
premières concitoyens consultation de
citoyens mais on va faire maintenant au
niveau européen et on avait une saisine
dans le cadre du centenaire de l'oit et
de l'organisation internationale du
travail sur la perception que les jeunes
ont de l'avenir du travail et donc on
avait mené des attitudes des ateliers
bon cette forme qui est très
intéressante et ce qui ressortit de tous
les jeunes qu'ils soient peu qualifiés
pas qualifiés du tout ou très qualifiés
l'un des freins principaux dans leur
parcours c'est les discriminations dont
ils ont ils ont tous mis en avant ce
premier sujet comment on lutte contre
les discriminations quelles qu'elles
soient femmes hommes handicap social et
donc c'est vraiment ce qu'ils ont ça
m'avait frappé parce que quel que soit
pas de plus leurs niveaux y compris même
leur origine sociale c'est vraiment le
premier sujet qui dit choqué le plus et
où disait il faut faire quelque chose
donc ça je vous les citer certains
jeunes et la deuxième chose que je
voudrais citer trois points importants
me semble-t-il j'ai la chance d'avoir en
ce moment donc d'un bureau parlementaire
à marseille un jeune en stage qui vient
de l'école j'ai enseigné devant donc
quel business school
et qui m'a proposé spontanément un plan
qu'il appelle marseille en jeunes
où il trouve que il ya trois points
importants
pour aller vers la jeunesse et l'égalité
des chances
le premier on a parlé c'est l'éducation
et l'éducation c'est aussi la rencontre
toujours avec un enseignant qui vous a
repéré qui vous a donné donc c'est tout
sujet des exemples
ça peut être d'autres jeunes qui donnent
envie à d'autres qui ont fait un
parcours en apprentissage
extraordinaires qui sont allés en europe
dont une mobilité et c'est toujours une
rencontre à un moment donné qui a fait
que hop on les a repérés il a envie de
faire autre chose oui c'est son cas et
massy dit me dit ça c'est vraiment un
point important il a voulu leur donner
le gall des associations il travaille
lui-même dans une association de votre
quête jeu s'appelle fénix qui est des
jeunes plus en difficulté à passer des
concours à progresser il ya cette
solidarité qui t'importe le deuxième
élément qui là cités qui lui trouve
majeur c'est la mobilité alors la
mobilité sociale géographique et c'est
là où effectivement je vois laurent ce
qui porte le sujet du statut repères de
l'apprentissage s'ils travaillent à fond
sur tous ces sujets qu'il en a également
c'est fondamental parce que ce n'est
c'est offrir effectivement cette
mobilité pas uniquement à des jeunes qui
sont déjà dans un
environnement social qui va faire qu'ils
vont avoir cette mobilité il y en a
plein qui en rêvent comme je disais à
l'époque quand je présidais la
concertation apprentissage avait
beaucoup dans les cfa on va reparler de
l'europe d'une mobilité des petites
étoiles dans les yeux qui soit en
apprentissage boulangerie du gier ah oui
j'aimerais bien aller en italie en
espagne en allemagne en autriche quel
rêve donc ce sujet de la mobilité
fondamentale avec donc mon jeune
stagiaire on est en train de préparer un
groupe promotion de corps européen de
solidarité pour des jeunes de la mission
locale dit qu'ils ne jamais il n'y
aurait pensé et qui du coup ont
peut-être pouvoir faire cette mobilité
et al'inverse accueillir un jeune dame
d'autriche qui va encadrer des jeunes
marseillais qui sont garantis jeunes
donc la mobilité et le troisième point
important qui lui a mis en avant la
communication
communiquer aussi avec le langage des
jeunes donc aller sur les sites qui vont
bien
instagram un peu moins à l'aise sur ces
sujets là je leur fais confiance parce
que souvent ils n'ont pas l'idée on n'a
pas des bons supports c'est l'accès à
tout ça alors l'apprentissage oui 500
mines a menti 40% d'augmentation c'est
génial mais on a encore trop de jeux de
parents qui viennent nous voir un peu
désespérée en dix ans mes gamins ils
trouvent pas ils trouvent pas de
contrats d'apprentissage c'était dur en
plus ces deux dernières années on sait
tous donc comment fait on développe
plein de choses géniales et vraiment je
rends hommage à ce gouvernement au
ministère du travail et tous les
ministères qui travaille là dessus parce
que c'est vraiment c'est génial un jeu
d'une solution fait tout ce qu'on a fait
c'est génial mais il ya encore un manque
il faut encore encourager l'accès voilà
les trois points qui me semble important
merci beaucoup sylvie nu
alors il nous laisse un intervenant
alors vous connaissez tous patrick
mignola mais déjà il faut dire qu'il a
réussi l'impossible mission de succéder
à marc fesneau à la tête à la présidence
du groupe parlementaire tulle a
magnifiquement réussi cette mission et
on a deux points communs je passe son
été rendu compte
d'abord tu parle autant de chats de
chambéry que moi je parle d'alsace ça
c'est à peu près le propre de tous les
députés on a tous les deux été chef
d'entreprise et tu vas nous parler d'un
sujet on qu'on partage dans nos
convictions qui est le sujet puisque
on a parlé de l'école on a parlé de
l'acquisition des compétences on a parlé
de l'accès à l'emploi mais l'égalité des
chances et aussi dans le monde de
l'entreprise et dans la façon notamment
dont on associe l'ensemble des salariés
à la réussite de l'entreprise et lorsque
j'étais dirigeant d'entreprise on avait
un pacte avec nos actionnaires un tiers
de la valeur pour les actionnaires sous
forme de dividendes un tiers de la
valeur pour les salariés sous forme de
primes participation résultats et un
tiers pour le développement de
l'entreprise ces impacts donc que j'ai
eu pendant huit ans évidemment
maintenant ça a changé bon maintenant
c'est 100% de dividendes pour une
société publique et c'était économique
ça pose question
mais ces modèles là qui considère que
associer les salariés au succès de
l'entreprise
et c'est tout à fait dans l'esprit
rhénan d'esprit du ce qu'on appelait à
une époque le capitalisme rhénan aimer
ce qu'on appelle plutôt le modèle social
rhénan je crois que tu le portes
profondément en toi tu nous en parle
souvent et j'aimerais que tu nous parles
de 7,2 ce sujet si important du monde de
l'entreprise à toi patrick
merci sylvain tu as parfaitement raison
en fait je reprendrai volontiers le le
récit là où sylvie vient de le laisser
sur tout ce qui nous reste encore à
faire
parce qu'en fait quand on parle du sujet
du partage de la valeur c'est un no
grand engagement n'est pas seulement de
cette famille politique en réalité c'est
l'engagement d'un pays qui a une passion
pour l'égalité il y en a et pour le
juste sert comment on répartit mieux la
valeur qu'est créée
entre le capital et le travail dont vous
savez tous que depuis une vingtaine
d'années il a évidemment beaucoup
augmenté en faveur du capital est
beaucoup moins que le travailler sans se
livrer un débat de chiffres on est là au
coeur d'une des réconciliations qu'il
faut organiser dans le pays
quand on parle d'égalité des chances
quand on parle de parts dissipation et
d'intéressement
de comment on reconnaît mieux le travail
et l'effort dans les entreprises au fond
on est exactement au coeur de l'égalité
des chances
d'abord parce qu'on est dans la justice
sociale
si on est capable
de maintenir un haut niveau de
croissance dans ce pays parce que on
sera mieux demain régler la question du
recrutement
et qu'on saura mieux intéresser les
jeunes qu'aujourd'hui on sort à travers
l'apprentissage de formation
professionnelle à travers l'école on
sait mieux les orienter vers de nouveaux
métiers grâce aussi à des bons niveaux
de rémunération
on maintiendra des niveaux de croissance
permettant de financer tout le reste
or quelle est notre sujet on peut pas
continuer à avoir autant de gens que ça
a été parfaitement décrits par les
intervenants avant moins autant de gens
qui sont éloignés qui sont sous les
radars la haut commissaire
qui parce qu'ils sont ils n'ont pas le
bon nom parce qu'ils sont pas nés au bon
endroit parce qu'ils n'ont pas les
relations qui ont tous les autres
qui seraient condamnés une forme domeo
stasi de la misère
il faut au contraire qu'on puisse
évidemment les accompagner mais cet
esprit de justice sociale où on est
capable de faire des passes et les états
dans lesquels on est né pour le françois
leur disais hier au détour d'une phrase
pour faire renaître l'homme dort l'homme
c'est exactement ça le l'engagement
humaniste ça rejoint aussi un sujet
d'efficience économique
parce que
le sujet dans le devant lequel on se
trouve vous le voyez bien on a eu cette
formidable chance je crois qu'on est à
contribuer par les décision qu'on a
prise mais que les françaises et les
français reviennent après la crise un
haut niveau de croissance personne
n'imaginait qu'on reviendrait au taux de
chômage d'avant la crise personne
n'imaginait qu'on ferait 7% de
croissance
exceptionnellement cette année mais
maintenant on a immédiatement le
problème du recrutement qui se pose
est évidemment il faut qu'on y réponde
par la réforme de l'assurance chômage
par l'accompagnement de la formation
professionnelle me disant les choses
on peut faire la réforme de l'assurance
chômage on peut continuer d'avancer
beaucoup plus fort en matière de
formation professionnelle mais si on
paye pas mieux les gens à un moment la
question de la rémunération elle va se
poser parce que on parle de sujets
contre des parker sur le btp
l'hôtellerie la restauration
on parle des nouveaux métiers du
numérique des nouvelles technologies de
la biotech très bien et on va inciter
les gens puisque ils changeront trois ou
quatre fois de métier dans leur vie à
aller vers ces métiers là
mais si le travail peut être un
épanouissement personnel il ya aussi la
capacité à mieux rémunérer ce type
d'emploi pour pouvoir attirer des jeunes
et des moins jeunes vers ces nouveaux
besoins de l'économie et là ça passe
effectivement par les combat que nous
devons mener maintenant
en matière de participation mais il ya
évidemment le grand sujet qui sera celui
de la prochaine législature parce que ça
se monte pas en deux mois faut pas dire
aux gens que je compromets maintenant
veulent réaliser au mois de janvier
c'est pas vrai et donc il faudra que la
généralisation de la participation à
toutes les entreprises y compris les
moins de 50 puissent être le premier
objet de 2022 au lendemain espérons-le
de la réélection du président de la
république mais là dès 2022 on pourrait
faire un déblocage de la participation
dans toutes les entreprises pour que les
français puissent participer eux aussi
au plan de relance en leur rendant
immédiatement du pouvoir d'achat y'a
rien qui a bien marché que de la prime
macron on pourrait doubler cette prime
macro rien qu'en libérant un peu d'être
de de participation salariés et puis en
matière d'intéressement il faut qu on
accompagne les tpe les pme permettre que
des accords d'intéressement puisse être
passé de façon unilatérale même
condamnant pas forcément un dialogue
social sur organisé parce que c'est
compliqué d'avoir des délégués syndicaux
dans les entreprises de 10 salariés
évidemment faut qu'on puisse faire des
plans d'intéressement qui sont sur cinq
ans parce que quand on suit ses
objectifs d'évolution et on pense
évidemment la transition écologique ça
dure plus tôt quatre ou cinq ans que
deux ou trois ans comme les plans
d'intéressement habituel et ça nous
allons le porter avec l'ensemble de la
majorité présidentielle je l'espère bien
des
le budget le budget de la sécurité
sociale et les prochaine niche
parlementaire qui seront portés par les
groupes de la république en marche et du
modem mais et je terminerai par là ça va
nous servir à deux choses non seulement
on remet de la justice sociale
non seulement on fait de l'efficience
économique mais ça va nous permettre en
plus
d'avoir plus de moyens parce que tout ce
qu'on vient de se dire sur l'école sur
la formation sur l'accompagnement le
mentorat dans les quartiers dans la
ruralité pour aller rechercher les
jeunes qu'il faut remettre dans la vie
professionnelle ça nécessite beaucoup de
moyens et c'est très important ce que
muriel pénicaud jean michel blanquer est
poursuivi par elisabeth borne
aujourd'hui on fait en début de
législature sur l'apprentissage mais
l'apprentissage ça coûte de l'argent on
va voir très vite l'année prochaine une
demande de la part des chefs
d'entreprise en particulier des plus
petits pour continuer l'aide à
l'apprentissage et il faut pas qu'on
casse la dynamique ça coûte il faut
qu'on réussisse d'aller au bout de la
réforme professionnels temps en temps il
faut qu'on secoue un peu les autres co
les opca c'est moi qui le dis comme ça
vous n'avez pas eu à le dire parce que
c'est pas interdit avec tout l'argent
que ça brasse qui soit un peu mieux
répartie c'est à dire et qu'on arrose
pas systématiquement là où c'est mouillé
et quand on prend de la formation
professionnelle aux petites entreprises
qu'on les donne pas pour gros ensuite
pour leurs salariés bref voilà je ferme
la parenthèse mais ça aussi ça coûte de
l'argent ça coûte de l'énergie et ça
coûte de l'argent également et puis en
matière d'école faucon poursuivre
l'effort et après le dédoublement de dcp
dans les zones d'éducation prioritaire
faudra probablement qu'on passe à la
grande section de maternelle et à ox et
eu un et qu'on le fasse aussi dans les
milieux ruraux et éloignés je sais que
nathalie travaille beaucoup sur ces
sujets là et là aussi ça coûte beaucoup
d'argent parce que c'est bien d'avoir
remis l'école sur le bon chemin
vous avez vous ai repris enfin la bonne
direction et les enseignants pour
rencontre aujourd'hui le dise bon c'est
bien mais nous disent aussi que ça
suffit pas nous disent que sur les
questions de rémunération
d'autorité de formation des enseignants
on n'y est pas tout à fait encore et ça
aussi ça nécessitera des moyens alors on
a abandonné le
l'abominable concept des 5 c qui
prévalait jusqu'à il ya longtemps il ya
peu de temps dans l'éducation nationale
c'est les 5 c d'éducation nationale
c'est c'est ce qu'on entendait le plus
sur le terrain quand on était maire
c'est con mais c'est comme ça c'est la
règle des 5 c
et là on s'est dit bon voilà on retrouve
un peu d'ambition
mais l'ambition ça se fait aussi avec de
l'argent et c'est pourquoi quand vous
êtes capable de réunir les objectifs de
justice sociale en réduisant au mieux
les salariés sur la base des rentabilité
des entreprises etc ainsi vous
nourrissez de la croissance pour recréer
de l'argent dans l'état pour pouvoir le
mettre là où il y en a besoin c'est
utile mais surtout
moi je crois que si on est capable de
d'augmenter les rémunérations dans ce
pays par un meilleur partage des
richesses
ça va nous permettre de faire une chose
c'est peut-être un peu provocateur ce
que je veux vous dire mais je le crois
fondamentalement
sexy on va tous vers une élévation
générale des salaires parce que chacun
va les chercher un 13e - 13e mois et
demi dans toutes les entreprises qui
font de la rentabilité ça va nous
permettre d'augmenter aussi les minima
sociaux
parce que moi je crois pas qu'on puisse
vivre aujourd'hui dignement dans ce pays
avec 700 800 euros par mois et que le
bon niveau de minima sociaux surtout si
demain on devait réunir l'ensemble de
ces minima pour les rendre plus simple
et plus accessible à tous nos
concitoyens il faudrait plutôt que la
barre elle soit autour de 1000 euros
pour le les plus nécessiteux
alors si on le fait à l'envers comme le
propose d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
gens dans nos oppositions où on fixe les
minima sociaux à 1000 euros sans
augmenter le reste des salaires on veut
juste assisté à un écrasement de
l'échelle des salaires et on va recréer
de l'injustice si en revanche on prend
les choses par le bon bout et que demain
on est capable de montrer à tous les
salariés de ce pays que tout effort
conduit à une augmentation salariale ça
permettra non seulement eux de les
entraîner vers plus de reconnaissance de
justice sociale et envie de tirer le
pays vers le haut étirant le pays vers
le haut ils tireront aussi ceux qui sont
en bas de l'échelle pour les sortir de
la situation dans laquelle ils sont et
ça aussi c'est l'égalité des chances
merci beaucoup patrick
voyer qu'il est parfaitement dans
l'express dans l'esprit économique et
social rhénan bravo et cette belle
démonstration bien nous allons passer
aux questions réponses nous avons 20
minutes sommes parfaitement dans le
timing alors rassurez vous je n'ai pas
favorisé les alsaciens sur la prise de
parole même même si on est quand même
venu à 18 du modem alsace 18 du madame
alsace un peu de souligner paul souligné
parce que c'est loin
bien on va prendre des questions alors
je vous préviens tout de suite si
souvent perchoir de l'assemblée
nationale
quand c'est trop long je coupe le micro
alors j'ai pas apporter mon petit bouton
pour couper le micro mais faites moi
confiance soit un moyen alors questions
courtes réponses on prend trois
questions à la fois avoue martin begag
modem paris alors j'espère que vous
allez pas me couper le micro je suis une
indigne et comme disait il en est ainsi
curel donc conséquente en cas digne et
poil à gratter que je vais prendre la
parole alors autour de cette table j'ai
envie de vous poser une seule question
avez vous déjà connu le chômage
très clair très clair c'est alors
j'attends la réponse pour et surtout à
madame là haut j'ai envie aussi de la
pause et en particulier à madame naveau
commissaire aux compétences
il ya énormément de choses à dire sur
ces sujets là on parle beaucoup et je
plaide sur ces sujets pour arrêter de
mettre les gens dans des cases depuis
très longtemps j'entends avec recul
on parle des jeunes des moins jeunes
donc l'égalité des chances ça peut
toucher tout le monde à tout moment sur
l'aspect compétents j'aurai beaucoup de
choses à redire parce que la formation
on a énormément d'organismes de
formation et d'argent aussi derrière
parfois des lobbys et se pose la
question de forme et pourquoi qui et
puis vous l'avez évoqué d'ailleurs
j'étais petit d'entre vous aujourd'hui
il ya aussi des gens j'ai écrit un
bouquin vous êtes trop qualifiée pour le
poste
maintenant il a dix ans malheureusement
il est encore tristement d'actualité et
je pense que c'est toute la vision du
marché du travail qu'il faut revoir et
comparé mieux quand on connaît le sujet
et quand on a eu la chance de connaître
le chômage et je peux d'autant plus en
parler aujourd'hui que je travaille dans
une association
qui a vocation à faire évoluer la
réglementation européenne la
réglementation financière européenne et
je suis passé par le chauvin j'ose le
dire tout comme ce matin richard ferrand
a dit qu'il était fils de maçon je suis
aussi une fille manon merci beaucoup
pour ce beau témoignage alors on prend
trois questions et puis on répondra à
nos intervenants répondront alors le
micro circulent oui elle est dans une
époque secours j'avais trois questions
la première c'est de dire qu'aujourd'hui
d'égalité défendre des chances il existe
en france parce que moi je suis issu de
l'immigration cambodgienne
j'ai échoué à l'école de la république
par contre j'ai fait une formation à
l'afpa pour être conduits tard travaux
je suis dans les tp donc aujourd'hui je
suis directeur d'une paix du pme
qui travaillait à tour par contre
l'égalité des chances moi mes parents
ont touché les allocations familiales
ils les ont orientés vers l'éducation de
leurs enfants
aujourd'hui
remettre des aides
sans doute pour ceux qui sont en dessous
de radars comme le dit mme patrick
mignot as c'est bien par contre c'est
aussi enlevé de la responsabilité des
parents de mieux orienter des aides
qu'aujourd'hui on donne en france
ça c'est une progression qui rejoint le
lait petit déjeuner à l'école alors
c'est bien pour ceux qui sont en dessous
du radar par contre responsabilité des
parents merci il faut peut-être remettre
ça en cause la deuxième c'est en effet
rarement sur deux questions est-ce que
vous êtes conscient que vous avez fait
ouais après je voulais poser une
question sur l'apprentissage oui moi
j'ai trois apprenties et apprentis
ingénieurs aujourd'hui on fait des
contrats d'apprentissage
pour être jury dans des écoles ou saisis
je vois bien que le niveau d'implication
des pme ou des
artisans sur l'apprentissage de leurs
élèves
meilleur je pense que sur des gros
groupes sauf qu'à la fin quand ils sont
diplômés
les gros groupes ont forcément plus de
pouvoir d'attraction dont quelques pme
par rapport aux grands groupes voilà
qu'elle est aujourd'hui le levier que
peu en disant bas je forme des gens et
je peux les garder derrière merci
beaucoup donc la différence entre pme et
grandes entreprises je voulais poser une
question de survie aux as ok pour monter
les
minimes un salaire des gens mais le
problème c'est toujours pareil c'est que
vous montez le salaire des gens
aujourd'hui on se bat pour pouvoir
d'achat vous aurez à vélo si les prix
donc on est dans une boue qu'un peu
infernal parfait c'est compris merci
beaucoup la troisième question enfin si
je puis dire les intervenants dominique
trop jeune ni rodez je voulais rebondir
sur ce que disait patrick mignola qui me
paraît extrêmement important la question
donc du pouvoir d'achat des salariés de
l'intéressement de la participation de
la rémunération du travail je pense
qu'en plus de toutes les vertus que l'on
peut trouver à ces aspects là il ya une
autre notre point qui n'est pas sans
intérêt également c'est que ça peut nous
permettre de gagner les élections
merci alors sur ses trois premières
interventions on va on va faire un petit
tour de table de ceux qui souhaitent
prendre la parole parmi vous
on a été notamment interpellé sur la
thématique des demandeurs d'emploi votre
vos expériences personnelles
éventuellement mais en tout cas voilà
c'est de cette question importante qui
veulent à traiter nathalie je veux bien
donc à la question avez vous déjà connu
le chômage la réponse est oui voilà
comme ça c'est très clair je vais
répondre à la question de monsieur sur
la responsabilité des parents et donc
sur les liens allocation est des
responsabilités en particulier sur le
petit déjeuner gratuit à l'école puisque
vous m'avez sollicité sur ce point
dans certaines communes sur certains
territoires je peux vous dire que c'est
absolument vital est donc là on lui très
clairement contre la précarité
alimentaire il n'empêche que ça n'est
pas la seule vocation du dispositif
c'est aussi de l'éducation à la santé
l'éducation à l'alimentation et ce
faisant quand des plus jeune âge encore
une fois on accompagne les enfants dans
ce que c'est que bien petit déjeuner
bien manger etc on a quand même résolu
déjà une bonne partie du problème enfin
sur le lien allocation aide
responsabilités des familles c'est un
autre débat c'est plutôt de la politique
familiale peut être qu'on en parlera
plus tard mais là encore je crois qu'il
ne faut pas faire l'amalgamme notamment
entre ce que l'on peut donner en termes
de politique sociale et d'allocations
familiales ce sont deux sujets bien
distincts mais peut-être que votre
question on ouvrait une troisième sur
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire est là
c'est à nouveau un autre un autre débat
et la responsabilité des familles oui
bien sûr qu'il faut aller les chercher
mais il ne faut pas non plus oublier que
parfois on a des enfants qui sont
vraiment en situation de grande
précarité et quoi qu'il arrive il faut
les aider merci à l'arrivée une question
importante sur vous êtes trop employés
potro qualifié pour ce poste on avait
parlé du décalage et du sentiment de
décalage entre les compétences et
l'emploi occupé sylvie est ce que tu
souhaites réagir
c'est une question très compliquée alors
d'abord à la question avez vous été au
chômage oui également
effectivement d'abord j'ai été drh 28
ans quand même dans mon existence je
connais un petit peu aussi des sujets
d'emploi de surqualification bon au
passage mon témoignage personnel j'ai
pris le premier
poste de drh qui s'offraient et je
gagnais moins qu'avec les allocations
chômage parce que j'étais cadre bon
quand même avec un certain niveau de
salaire et donc je l'écris quand même
tout de suite en me disant il faut aller
vite sur l'emploi et bien en a pris
puisque quelques mois après j'ai été
chassé pour un poste de drh d'un grand
groupe qui regroupe honnête donc au
passage c'est important aussi le retour
à l'emploi c'est pas forcément attendre
trop bon le sujet de la surqualification
il est complexe parce que
c'est tout le sujet aussi
des métiers de leur révolution
de l'information il ya le lien avec la
formation professionnelle bien
évidemment et c'est la responsabilité
aussi des entreprises que de savoir
faire évoluer leurs salariés alors de
mon point de vue encore et maintenant ça
fait longtemps que ce que des rages
souvent pas assez pris en compte au
niveau le plus stratégique
moi j'ai toujours travaillé avec
l'économique donc on ne peut pas
concevoir par exemple la transition
environnementale la transition du
végétal sans se demander qu'est ce que
ça va impliquer sur des emplois les
métiers à plus ou moins long terme c'est
une réflexion qui manque souvent au
passage et donc ça relève de sa savoir
faire évoluer les gens les formes et
investir beaucoup sur la formation pour
éviter qu'on soit à un moment donné jugé
sur qualifiés ou avoir le ressenti
d'être surqualifiés c'est vrai aussi son
on a souvent parlé au du du burn out il
ya aussi le bord out des gens qui
s'ennuient au travail parce que c'est
tout le sujet de la rh qui est très
compliqué et je voulais juste aussi
répondre sur les pme des tpe pme sur
l'apprentissage d'une question majeure
il ya des gîtes en plus de beau parcours
à faire dans les petites entreprises
qu'on connaît moins bien et d'ailleurs
on parlait des jeunes tout à l'heure
souvent ils ont envoyé leur cv ils vont
s'adresser aux grands groupes qui sont
visibles qu'ils connaissent c'est
beaucoup plus difficile pour les plus
petites entreprises et je pense que pour
aller garder après c'est une vraie
question
il faut arriver à travers ça rejoint ce
que tu disais patrick sur des
dispositifs de rémunération avec
d'un intéressement de l'action gratuite
j'ai moi même travaillé dans une start
up qui est devenue maintenant
aujourd'hui chez thales s'étaient j'aime
plus gemalto qui aujourd'hui thalès en
fait on n'était pas extrêmement bien
rémunérés à l' embauche mais à mais il
ya eu des plans d'action de l'octroi
d'actions gratuites sas et c'est voilà
les intéressés au développement de la
prise ils vont faire sûrement très beau
parcours et enfin il faut raisonner
parcours professionnel on va faire toute
sa vie dans la même entreprise merci
karim élections et après on passe la
parole à quatre entre rapidement alors
moi j'ai connu la situation de beaucoup
de jeunes diplômés de prendre un moment
avant de rentrer dans le marché du
travail et c'est ce que nos jeunes
diplômés on connaissait déjà avant la
crise est sans doute ce que la crise a
renforcé c'est une période ces
différentes périodes de chômage quand on
a déjà travaillé qu'on se retrouve au
chômage mais c'est une période qui est
une période aussi de très grandes
remises en question de d'avoir du mal à
se projeter et se dire on ne sait pas si
on a une place quoi et donc
je vois ça c'est pour répondre à deux
questions je voudrais quand même dire
que en fait
heureusement que la capacité
d'indignation et la capacité à agir ne
dépend pas de l'expérience personnelle
qu'on a qu'on aa pas qu'ils des
situations d'injustice sinon on
risquerait d'avoir une société très
fracturée
et une chose politique est une chose
publique
finalement assez peu développé et donc
je revendique le fait d'être au
commissaire aux compétences et de ne
jamais avoir été au chômage et je
revendique le fait d'être une indigne et
fort heureusement que ceux qui sont au
ski ont été aussi dans l'inclusion porte
une capacité à s'indigner et à agir pour
les autres je crois que c'est même en
réalité ce qui fonde un parti politique
est un mouvement
donc ça c'est mes jeux vraiment
j'insiste là dessus parce que je trouve
que sinon on bascule vite dans
voilà
alors il y avait beaucoup de questions
la question de la responsabilité des
parents la question de l'assistanat la
question de à quoi ça sert finalement en
toile de fond dans ce que vous avez dit
est ce que l'on fait pas de
l'occupationnel parce que la formation
pour les vulnérables à quoi ça sert il
ya un peu cette idée que tout ça
finalement sert à occuper les jambes
mais est ce qu'on les emmène vraiment
quelque part d'abord je vais dire une
chose très importante c'est que la
formation ne crée pas l'emploi la
formation ne crée pas l'emploi en
revanche le défaut de port formation
peut créer du chômage ce qui n'est pas
exactement la même chose
et ça c'est très important et notre
responsabilité à nous est en tout cas la
mienne celle telle que je la conçois
c'est de faire en sorte que l'on
construise des parcours professionnels
pour des gens qui ont eu des accidents
de vie des jeunes et des moins jeunes
parfois d'ailleurs totalement
involontaire
vers des métiers verts des emplois qui
existent et pour lequel nous avons des
besoins ça envoie un peu la question des
métiers en tension je partage assez
évidemment ce qu'a dit à patrick tout à
l'heure il ya quand même un petit bout
qu'il faut qu'on prenne ou sûr il faut
s'assurer qu'on a on oriente bien les
gens conforme vers l'est vers les
métiers les emplois d'aujourd'hui les
métiers de demain donc évidemment vers
quoi en forme on forme vers les besoins
des entreprises vers les besoins publics
des associations aussi
éventuellement de la fonction publique
et il ya beaucoup de besoins nouveaux la
crise a changé aussi peut-être une
partie des chaînes de valeur ou à
révéler des éléments on a une d'énormes
besoins dans les métiers du numérique on
a des métiers enfin des emplois en
tension c'est à dire des entreprises qui
passent par milliers par dizaines de
milliers qui cherchent des compétences
dans numérique dans l'industrie dans le
bâtiment dans la construction nos
métiers sont en train d'évoluer à la
faveur de la révolution de la
transformation numérique et de la
transformation de la conversion
écologique
on voit bien que la crise a aussi montré
à quel point on avait des besoins dans
le domaine du soin de la santé du
service à la personne les aides
soignantes les auxiliaires de vie on a
un nouvelle mais on a un nouveau modèle
de société a inventé et c'est vers tous
ces métiers qu'il faut orienter et donc
évidemment je n'ai pas forcément
développer parce que il y aurait
beaucoup de choses à dire mais on a une
préoccupation qui est extrêmement forte
qui est de former ces personnes jeunes
ou moins jeunes vers ces métiers
d'avenir et c'est en soi un exercice
permanent parce qu'en fait l'autre
question c'est que on pensait avant
qu'on avait un modèle à peu près clair
mais aujourd'hui en les transformations
des métiers sont beaucoup plus rapides
et donc il faut garder une capacité à
adapter les compétences quasiment en
permanence et donc on raisonne plutôt de
changer totalement des parcours de
formation ce qui met dix ans de pouvoir
injecter par des logiques de modules de
compétences de briques de compétences
pour les salariés enfin pour les
demandeurs d'emploi mais aussi pour les
salariés les besoins nouveaux des
entreprises et c'est aussi ce qui permet
de banaliser l'accès à la formation on
va pas se refermer complètement toute la
vie on va partir de ce qu'on sait déjà
valorisé ce qu'on sait déjà et complétée
et moi je crois encore une fois cette
société où en fait on va continuer par
brique à se former tout au long de la
vie que ça devienne cet acte un peu
normal courant et c'est ce qui permettra
de répondre à ces nouveaux besoins merci
beaucoup car il alors patrick quelques
mots tu la vision ta vision rhénane de
l'école du social a été largement
approuvé plébiscité par les deux
interventions est ce que tu souhaitais
réagi choses qui avaient été posées
notamment sur la soutenabilité des
modèles augmentation des augmentations
des nounous suivre comme ça on pourra
prendre les dernières questions mais
juste le nôtre intervenant au fond de la
salle qui peut devenir premier ministre
puisque le dernier qui m'a appelé
mignola ce dans l'hémicycle c'était jean
castex en fait
donc ne mettez pas de s à mignola ce que
les députés du groupe en serait
malheureux si on était plusieurs quoi
ces paroles de sagesse alors on va jouer
au jeu des flashs question j'ai négocié
jusqu'à 12h45 donc on a le temps de
prendre plusieurs questions si c'est des
flashs questions et des flashs réponse
donc le principe des flashs question
avec la réponse est une minute 1 alors
on va répartir le micro question flash à
l'isi ben je vais je vais être rapide
donc on n'a pas le temps je me pose la
question aux 6 est ce que vous
connaissez déjà le dispositif la promo 6
10 8
l'aqua pardon la promo 6 10 8 est ce que
vous pouvez
oui la promo 6,18 qui vient d'être créée
en 2020 moi je travaille à l'afp a donc
ma spécialité c'est l'insertion et
l'accompagnement j'aimerais bien savoir
est ce que vous connaissez la promo
c'est juste parce qu'il ya tellement
dispositif que finalement même les
jeunes super et les professionnels aussi
donc je vous pose la question j'aimerais
bien une réponse de celle qui va merci
alors on va prendre trois questions
alors une question là bas je crois que
monsieur lève là et vous madame vous
aurez la parole ne vous inquiétez pas
donc
deuxième là bas
allez-y madame vous êtes de madame alesi
et puis après ça bonjour christelle
esclangon val de marne alors je suis
professeur des écoles je vais pas trop
venir sur l'école primaire parce que
vous avez dit l'essentiel si ce n'est
que effectivement c'est une vraie
réussite et vous pouvez en être très
fiers et nous en sommes très contents
dans les écoles mais ne pas oublier
quand même de ne pas que vous occupez
des écoles auraient plus enfin en zone
d'éducation prioritaire moi je suis élue
municipale dans une ville comme des
juifs je ne sais pas si vous connaissez
oui où il ya énormément d'écoles en zone
prioritaire mais aussi des écoles qui
sont juste à la limite et qui mon dieu
aurait besoin de ce dispositif plus plus
plus donc ne les oubliez pas parce que
souvent mais beaucoup beaucoup de moyens
sur ce serait pour l'égalité des chances
dans ces écoles là mais c'est la
ministre qui vous répondra juste une
petite chose parce que moi vraiment très
petit veut faire avait dit très rapide
simplement au delà de l'école
élémentaire gelé vécu moi avec mon
dernier enfant je trouve que il ya un
sujet qu'on n'a pas abordé pour
l'égalité des chances et le problème de
l'orientation au niveau du collège dans
notre pays salaire de catastrophe bien
on en parlera
s'il faut vraiment travailler là-dessus
avec les systèmes de tutorat comme dans
les champs des écoles dites on a bien
repris la question de l'orientation
collège c'est vraiment très important la
troisième edouard jacque élus et chefs
d'entreprises du nord lorrain
transfrontalier moi je voulais parler de
l'égalité des chances mais dans le
domaine de l'apprentissage des langues
aujourd'hui sur les territoires quand on
vit sur rue dans une métropole on a plus
de chances d'accéder à l'apprentissage
des langues que lorsqu'on ne les
donnerai pas ces industries en
difficulté ou lorsqu'on est en milieu
rural ou dans ces secteurs en difficulté
or des avancées ont été faites certes on
ne peut pas les nier mais on est encore
dans la politique des petits pas regarde
ce qui se passe à travers les pays
d'europe notamment ceux d'europe du nord
mais pas exclusivement d'europe du nord
ce qu'on peut regarder au monténégro la
totalité de la population parle anglais
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est comme
le numérique une véritable fracture qui
est en train de se passer parce que on a
le sentiment que ceux qui peuvent y
accéder y accèdent encore plus content
que ceux qui n'y a c'est pas du tout on
les pires difficultés pour y accéder je
l'aï il ya une véritable révolution à
faire et plus seulement des merci
beaucoup alors 3 flash réponse la
première c'est nathalie sur la question
d'équipé vais sur la question des
réseaux d'éducation prioritaire et du
soutien que l'on apporte à nos élèves en
éducation prioritaire alors on fait
beaucoup en éducation prioritaire parce
que dans l'éducation prioritaire ya
prioritaires justement voilà donc ça
quand même c'est une chose je les dis on
a dédoublé 100% des classes de cp et de
ce1 en est à 74 % des classes de grande
section en dehors de l'éducation
prioritaire sur les petites classes on
est en train progressivement d'atteindre
le niveau de classe à 24 élèves maximum
donc c'est également c'est une avancée
enfin sur les écoles que vous dites être
en périphérie à la frontière notamment
du zonage de l'éducation prioritaire je
vais parfaitement
vu ça en arrivant à l'année dernière et
justement on est en train de mener une
expérimentation en ce champ en ce sens
sur trois académies pour l'instant lille
nantes et aix marseille le zonage c'est
très bien sauf quand on est dans le
zonage en à 100% des moyens quand on est
à côté on a zéro et donc ce que l'on est
en train de faire c'est que pour tout ce
qui est autour sur ces trois académies
concrètement on travaille à l'échelle de
l'unité éducative de l'école du collège
du collège rural même des lycées qui ne
sont plus en éducation prioritaire on
travaille avec les équipes on travaille
avec les acteurs locaux on regarde le
projet on regarde le besoin et en
fonction on donne des moyens ça
s'appelle les contrats locaux
d'accompagnement parfait merci beaucoup
karine vous répondre à la première
question qui avait été posée
je t'ai faire le lien sur deux questions
mais très bien alors je connais la promo
16-18 il se trouve que j'ai l'immense
responsabilité de porter ce dispositif
car des dispositifs du plan
effectivement une solution le principe
c'est un des dispositifs qui accompagne
l'obligation de formation des jeunes de
16 à 18 ans vous le savez sans doute le
parlement a voté l'année dernière
une obligation de formation pour les
jeunes de 16 à 18 ans notre obligation
de scolaire va jusqu'à 16 ans la
question c'est qu'est ce qui se passe
après 16 ans alors n'a pas voulu
prolonger l'obligation scolaire jusqu'à
18 ans mais dire que la finalement
l'obligation de formation c'est une
obligation qui pèsent sur la puissance
publique sur la réponse que l'on apporte
qui consiste à apporter une réponse de
formation à des jeunes au delà de
l'obligation scolaire c'est-à-dire après
16 ans pour ceux qui seraient en fait
décrocheurs sans avoir acquis un premier
niveau de qualification et donc la promo
ça 18,1 des dispositifs c'est un
dispositif que qui en a confié à l'afpa
qui accueille des jeunes de 16 à 18 ans
décrocheurs scolaires un cadre
bienveillant des tout petits groupes à
des tout petits effectifs ils sont dix
tout petit effectif un cadre
bienveillant un cadre dans lequel cinq
centres de formation qui accueille des
adultes ou par ailleurs le formateur
qu'à l'habitude de parler à des adultes
s'adresse à ces jeunes comme des adultes
donc ça change le regard aussi la
représentation
découverte et donc qu'est ce qui fonde
la découverte des métiers sur des
plateaux techniques
ils font de l'aide à la construction du
projet ils vont faire des immersions en
entreprise ça dure entre trois et quatre
mois et l'idée c'est de les remettre sur
des rails leurs frères faire découvrir
ce qu'ils auraient envie de faire pour
aller soit vers l'apprentissage soit en
retour en formation initiale parce que
certains peuvent avoir envie de
retourner en lycées professionnels
en formation professionnelle dans le
cadre que vous que je finance dans le
cadre formation continue faire un
service civique bref se révéler donc
c'est un cadre bray bienveillant où on
n'est pas jugée pour pouvoir respirer
c'est un sas de respiration pour se
projeter et donc la question c'est aussi
ça peut être un débouché au collège
alors on a un sujet peu avant dans la
relation au collège bien un sujet
collège qui est un sujet majeur
évidemment c'est quoi la bordée ça fait
partie de ces sujets qui sont
qui qu'on va parler réglé dans les six
mois mais qui sont un des sujets de la
campagne et sur lequel il faut vraiment
qu'on réfléchisse comment est-ce qu'on
s'attaque à ça aujourd'hui on a mis
cette rustine qui est formidable et je
remercie l'ensemble des formateurs de
l'afpa qui accompagnent ces gosses enfin
ces jeunes pardon mais il faut aller
effectivement il va falloir s'attaquer
un peu aux racines et la question du
collège vous avez raison merci de me
donner l'occasion de le dire c'est
fondamental consensus sur ce sujet là
ilana répond à la question d' edouard
jacque oui oui alors merci de la
question des langues alors qu'une
première réponse qui n'est pas vraiment
une réponse mais une information c'est
que demain c'est la journée européenne
des langues et lundi je serai en
déplacement avec jean michel blanquer
jean-michel lanka va faire des annonces
sur le plan langues donc je vous appelle
le 27 je veux pas lui griller la
priorité mais c'est au coeur en tout cas
de nos priorités et je vous invite donc
à être à l'écouté le 27 maintenant je
voudrais vous répondre il ya des moyens
et ça c'est très important et mais il ya
aussi qu'est-ce qu'on fait d'un point de
vue pédagogique et là je vais vous
répondre justement comme députée
européenne qui est en train d'assister
c'est ça que je veux partager avec vous
à l'apparition de l'est de l'europe de
l'éducation l'europe de l'éducation
c'est des meilleures pratiques vous avez
on le sait très bien en europe des gens
qui sont bien meilleurs que nous pour la
transmission des langues je pense par
exemple au danemark ou en suède donc ce
que ce qu'on est en train de soi quand
on est en train d'assister de participer
à travers les académies européenne des
professeurs j'ai pas le temps d'en
parler c'est un nouvel outil ce sont
deux sets enfin nous nous donnons les
moyens d échanges de bonnes pratiques et
demain dans nos écoles oui je rêve mais
c'est pas un rêve c'est une réalité
puisqu'il a les moyens pour donc il ya
cette dynamique et la france est
vraiment fer de lance dans cette
dynamique non seulement de donner les
moyens mais aussi de changer les
pratiques de s'inspirer de ce qu'ils
sont les meilleurs notamment aux langues
mais l'irlande pour le numérique
l'allemagne pour l'apprentissage la
finlande pour tout ce qui est
compétences psychosociales à ce qu'on
appelle les sauces qu'ils en fait on est
une puissance éducative européenne et on
ne le sait pas encore on fait maison on
se donne les moyens et sur les landes je
vous suis et je conclurai en disant que
moi je je vous tends la main pour que ce
soit nos grands sujets de campagne et
pas pour que tous les jeunes français
parlent mieux la langue au moins deux
langues et se donner les moyens de
changer nos pratiques de questionner nos
pratiques il n'y a aucune raison qu'on
n'y arrive pas journée dans votre voix
merci oui nanard des deux dernières
questions donc madame alors c'est
vraiment des questions très courte et
des réponses très court
depuis 25 ans entre le temps j'ai
remplacé dans ses médecins donc ce que
je voulais dire c'est que je suis très
contente que le modem le modem parle de
l'égalité des chances parce que j'aime
sujet primordial
c'est c'est dommage que certains
nous parlent de nous parler de commandes
de la théorie du remplacement ou je sais
pas quoi avait donc alors que les
questions sur sa lancée remercie pour ce
voyage juste de
donner le petit déjeuner c'est très
important pour ces enfants parce qu'il y
en a qui ne mangent pas de matin voila
voila merci la deuxième question et ça
va être très court parce que j'essaie
d'aller très très vite c est pour la
réforme des médecins j'ai eu une
remontée par des étudiants cette réforme
elle est très bien mais il faudra
améliorer des petites choses on peut
annuler l'oral qui est dans dans cette
réforme ce serait très bien parce que
des gens comme nous qui venons de la
diversité nous sur sa dette on n'est pas
dans ce format que c'est les enfants de
médecins qui sont pris et c'est pas dans
google merci au québec les voyages merci
une dernière intervention là bas
alors je vous rassure parce que nos
intervenants restent là vous pourrez à
table discuter avec eux dernière flash
question
non non non non non non je ne mangeais
négocier vous inquiète pas c'est sous
contrôle flash question rapidement sur
très rapidement elle y retiennent chez
lui dans le val d'oise alors moi je suis
très étonné parce qu'on parle d'égalité
des chances mais on n'a pas évoqué
l'entrepreneuriat qui pour moi je
considère que c'est une des solutions
aussi pour réduire les inégalités donc
du coup je m'adresse à patrick
vous qui avez été tiré en entreprise
n'est ce pas une solution n'est ce pas
un travail que l'on doit développer pour
finalement réduire cette inégalité que
l'on a au départ merci merci beaucoup
alors très rapidement qui souhaitent
répondre patrick un mot oui bien sûr
faut inciter à l'entrepreneuriat pour ça
il faut faire deux choses donner une
culture d'entreprise c'est à dire on le
disait à l'instant avec la
haut-commissaire en aparté on a besoin
notamment de faire connaître la culture
d'entreprise dès le collège et pas
seulement avec une petite ouverture de
une semaine pour aller faire le stage de
troisième et la deuxième chose c'est
qu'il faut aussi protéger et je sais pas
si vous avez regardé ce que le président
de la république avait annoncé il ya un
truc qu'on a un peu raté dans cette
législature c'est la promesse qui était
de créer une assurance chômage
quand on y jouait dans le monde de
l'entreprise or le monde de l'entreprise
c'est un échec parfois parfois c'est à
dire il peut profiter d échec est
l'échec d'ailleurs permet ensuite de
rebondir pourvu qu'on soit accompagnée
sauf que en fait on a voté la
disposition puis après les passer dans
les mains d'une administration qui l'a
tellement saoul appliquée que ça a
concerné deux mille personnes en france
voilà donc choisir la république a fait
des annonces permettant d'ouvrir un
droit à l'assurance chômage pour les
entrepreneurs de l'elsass hongrie le
l'incapacité à porter atteinte au
patrimoine personnel des entrepreneurs
notamment indépendant quand ils se
montrent pouvoir travailler pour avoir
des taux notamment de d'application
de charges sur l'assurance des accidents
du travail et permettent d'avoir un
accès plus simple aux crédits c'est un
de la culture et puis deux des solutions
parce que en fait s'il ya 25 ans on
devient chef d'entreprise on n'a pas
envie d'être plantés à 28,6 jamais ça
marchait pas bon il est 12h 45 on a tenu
le times je devrais quand même vous dire
vous remercier pour ses interventions et
ses témoignages je voudrais dire en tant
que législateur pour conclure d'une
phrase que toutes ces lois servent si
elles sont mises dans les faits et que
le problème de l'égalité des chances
c'est le problème de la loi et aussi le
problème de la réalité des faits et
qu'on a tous du coup une responsabilité
pour agir merci beaucoup pour cette
table ronde passionnante
[Applaudissements]